every day many Americans wake up
worrying about the mental health of a
family member or loved one an estimated
forty seven point six million adults in
the u.s. experienced mental illness last
year that's one in five adults in this
country this morning we're announcing an
upcoming special show to address this
urgent issue CBS this morning will
broadcast a live Town Hall stop the
stigma a conversation about mental
health that's on October 23rd will
feature a live studio audience of people
affected by mental illness in various
ways dr. sue Varma is among the experts
who will participate in the townhall
she's a fellow of the American
Psychiatric Association one of the many
organizations we're consulting with for
this special show and she joins us now
sue thank you for being here thank you
for having me so stigma and mental
health these these concepts are
intertwined and they shouldn't be in
this country what is the impact of
stigma on people's ability to get the
help they need yes it is very
detrimental stigma is about lack of
education lack of awareness and
sometimes even when people have both it
comes down to a lack of compassion and
empathy right so we have an
understanding but what are we going to
do how is it going to translate into
action and that's what we need we need
action we need people on every level to
understand that not getting the help
that we need only makes the problem
worse when we have stigma we are
creating shame and we're creating blame
would we blame somebody for having type
1 diabetes no absolutely not when we
blame somebody for having the flu when
we blame someone for having a broken arm
this is no different they blame and
shame gets you nowhere but yet it exists
why why do you think that there's still
after all this time and so many
well-known people have come out talking
about people have members in their
family who also suffer from mental
illness yet it's still there why we
don't think of the brain as an organ
when we see somebody's behavior we think
that they have the capacity to change
but the reality is that a lot of times
people are not even aware of the
symptoms that they're having half the
time right and we need to know what are
those symptoms somebody says just snap
out of it if you had a 103 degree fever
and you were suffering from the flu how
effective is that if your family members
said snap out it what are some of the
most significant stigmas that we that we
still have yes that we think that
somebody can change if they're drinking
if they're abusing substances we think
that this is some more
failure that they didn't try hard enough
right but you know one thing that's
interesting is when people die by
suicide if we were to think of it as
somebody dying by cancer how would it
change right like the person didn't want
to live and that leaves anytime you have
a mental illness or you have suicide it
affects not only a family a society
community people who are left behind
feel like failures people who are
experiencing it feel like failures
talking about it the way we are now that
helps break down the stigma but what
else can we do the science is clear the
health ramifications are clear how do we
break through to really change this this
this system I think it's so important
that people who are celebrated in our
community who are seen as very strong if
they're able to come out and share their
struggles as we have seen we see that
this can be a part of a normal person's
life if we're talking about one in five
people we look around the room right
here all of us are struggling with
something at some point in our lives so
normalizing it and people who are we put
on pedestals who are heroes they need to
come out we need to also be open when
we're struggling with something we need
to shed a positive light if you're going
to share with your friend the best
restaurant that you've been to why can't
you tell them the best therapist that
you've ever been to talk about the
positive experiences of getting help
focus on that ass and struggling with
things like what because you hear mental
illness and that's a very big brush yes
so mental illness struggling with what
yes for example so for example if you're
dealing with what we call major
depressive disorder somebody's saying
that I have difficulty getting motivated
I don't want to get out of bed I'm I've
lost pleasure and the things that I once
used to I'm finding that I'm gaining
weight I can't concentrate as much I'm
feeling very anxious I'm paralyzed
I'm ruminating I'm having difficulty
making decisions what somebody says I'm
having fluctuations in my moods if
they're talking about bipolar disorder
sometimes I feel like I'm very elated I
feel like I have periods in my in my
life when I have episodes when I can get
a lot of work done
I feel grandiose I feel like I can buy a
lot of things I'm buying things in
different colors and everything
impulsive isn't it true though so that
sometimes people don't recognize they're
even know this is the problem yes we
don't know this upon because they think
there's a difference between going back
to a baseline if you're coming out of a
depression and you're going into manic
episode we need to recognize it and we
also need to talk about it dr. sue Varma
thank you very much the conversation
starts now and it's gonna continue CBS
CBS this morning special live townhall
stop the stigma a conversation about
mental health will air October 23rd and
look for continued coverage in the days
leading up to the show and
as we call attention to this important
topic and Sue Varma will be back on that
day look forward to seeing you again
thanks